أليس الأمر هو أنك تجد جميعًا أن إيران
تشكل التهديد الأكبر في الوقت الحالي ، ولهذه
الغاية ، أعتقد بالتأكيد أنك
كنت تقابل إسرائيليين معينين في
نيويورك كنتم في كنيس
مع مسؤول استخبارات إسرائيلي سابق ،
إفرايم هاليفي.  إنك
تحاول أنه من مصلحة المملكة العربية السعودية أن تقوم
بطريقة ما بتدفئة العلاقات مع إسرائيل
والتحدث مع الإسرائيليين بطريقة
لم تفعلها من قبل لأن لديك هذا
العدو المشترك ، والمفارقة أن
صب السلمون هو أن إسرائيل تستغل
القضية الفلسطينية باعتبارها  هذا كبش
فداء لأفعالهم ليس
مهمًا بالنسبة لنا الآن لأن إيران هي
العدو الرئيسي والاعتقاد بأن المملكة
العربية السعودية ستتعاون مع إسرائيل بينما
لا تزال تحتل الأراضي الفلسطينية والأراضي
السورية والأراضي اللبنانية
والقدس كما قلت.  نعم إنهم
لا يعرفون ما الذي يتحدثون
عنه من يقول جيدًا لماذا إذن
من مصلحتك الظهور على خشبة المسرح
في كنيس في نيويورك مع إفرايم
هاليفي  أورمر ، رئيس الموساد ، حسنًا ،
إنه لإخبار الشعب الإسرائيلي أن
فلسطين هي القضية الأولى بالنسبة لنا
وأن من مسؤوليتهم
الوصول إلى تسوية سلمية وفقًا
لخطة السلام السعودية ، ومبادرة السلام العربية ،
ولهذا السبب أتحدث إلى
اليهود.  الجماهير في أمريكا
وأماكن أخرى والتقى مع X
المسؤولين الإسرائيليين والسيد.  كان هولواي
نفسه يحث الحكومة الإسرائيلية على
قبول حل الدولتين
والدخول في مفاوضات جادة مع
الفلسطينيين بشأن هذه القضية